um it's just humiliating also very  confused by his style because he doesn't  make any  sensible moves no offense but somehow he  keeps tricking me  um just blitzing out stuff bishop b4  takes bishop d3 are you serious  either he's the biggest genius in the  world or this is weird  yeah this looks way way over my head  i'm not sure what's going on there mr  solomon that's too strong for me  it should be four followed by bishop d3  wow  yeah i guess i can resign here with a  clear conscience right  d2 takes  yeah no hope  good game good game but yeah some crazy  moves there  played instantly  yeah i don't know that was a very  strange game  good game mr salomon very confusing game  really